mural bowser the democrat mayor of
washington d.c has just declared a
public emergency in the district after
11 000 illegal aliens have arrived on
buses that were sent from texas and
arizona now that number is nothing
compared to the total number of illegal
aliens who pour across the border into
border towns every single day
but for some reason mayor bowser thinks
it constitutes a state of emergency
which is really strange
since i have been reliably informed by
the liberal media that mass illegal
migration i'm sorry i'm sorry they call
it diversity
is actually our greatest strength
so how is it maybe you can help me
figure this out how is it that our
greatest strength
is now an emergency luckily we have dc
council lady brianne nadeau to explain
so
it's been said but it's worth
reiterating
that the governors of texas and arizona
have created this crisis
and the federal government has not
stepped up to assist the district of
columbia so we
along with our regional partners will do
what we've always done we'll rise to the
occasion we've learned from border towns
like el paso and brownsville
and in many ways
the governors of texas and arizona
have turned us into a border town we
don't know how long this will take
to resolve we don't know how long they
will continue busing
you hear that
those awful red state governors have
turned liberal washington d.c
into a border town
could you imagine the horror even though
wait a minute
haven't liberal politicians in
washington dc been telling us that
there's nothing bad at all going on in
the border towns because illegal
immigration is our strength what's so
bad about becoming a border town i
thought it was perfectly fine to be oh
now now you're experiencing it
and you're realizing it's not so great
when it's in your backyard just a few
years ago this very same lady this
council lady who is complaining about
illegal aliens showing up in dc tweeted
out quote
the district is a sanctuary city which
means our law enforcement does not
cooperate with ice
as council member i have called for an
abolition of ice and wrote dc's law to
establish a permanent immigrant legal
services fund
but you see
you see that was
back when illegal immigrants were not
really showing up to washington d.c
back when illegal immigration was a
problem created by washington
politicians for red states to deal with
now that dc is getting a taste of its
own medicine the lies and the
disingenuous narratives are falling
apart and even the libs themselves are
tacitly admitting that the only reason
they consider illegal immigration to be
our strength is that it allows them to
weaken their political opponents namely
us
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from allen921 who
says i think if it were at all possible
the video about the life of queen
elizabeth ii would have been a great
eulogy we didn't just lose an amazing
woman we have lost what little remains
of the traditional western culture god
save the queen thanks so much i really
appreciate that you know i did my show
yesterday and then there was news that
the queen was ailing and then she died
uh not not long after the show a few
hours after the show and i knew i had
the show today but i just felt the
moment was so
important and it was eliciting rightly
justifiably i think a very strong
reaction from people i said i've just
got to go live i got to do an extra show
today and so that's up on youtube i
think we put it on the rss feed as well
uh that's where most of my thoughts on
the passing of queen elizabeth will be
but i i've been really uh
surprised maybe i shouldn't have been
surprised because i know that she was so
beloved um but i've i've been really
pleased to see the positive response
that that video has gotten i've gotten a
lot of messages in particular from from
the uk and from overseas but i
appreciate that if you want to hear that
you can go to the rss feed or
elsewhere on the youtube channel
you know because the woman was really
important she was described as a golden
thread
uniting the entire
united kingdom and speaking of gold have
you checked out birchgold right now text
knowles to
989898 the biden administration recently
announced a plan to hire
87 000 new irs agents in 2023. many of
whom will be bearing arms as they hunt
for your money
you need to secure your savings in a tax
sheltered account right now not
yesterday
not not tomorrow do it right now okay
birch gold can help you do just that
birch gold group helps you hold gold and
silver in a tax sheltered retirement
account to protect you from
the government plus throughout history
gold has always been your best hedge
against inflation a diversified savings
can protect you from downturns in the
market if you have a 401k or ira that is
underperforming just text knolls to
989898
and you can convert that into an ira in
precious metals right now birch gold
group has an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless five
star reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers text knowles kennedy wles to
989898 and birch gold will send you a
free info kit on diversifying into gold
tax free take the necessary steps to
hedge against inflation today protect
your hard-earned money get your free
info kit now by texting knolls to 989898
that is the big story of course right
now is the passing of queen elizabeth
and it's
it's taken the whole focus of the world
because people feel as though
a great age is gone now you know our our
last connection to this great age when
western civilization seemed to flourish
more seem to make more sense
is finally gone we knew it was going to
come the woman was 96 years old but it
doesn't make it any less sad
there have been some really off-key
responses i've noticed this
uh especially from people on the left
who
while they well they may actually have
liked the woman and while they may be
trying to be polite on her passing
they they don't like monarchy they don't
like tradition they don't like western
civilization so they don't really like
anything that the woman stood for
and and so it's created a real
challenge in the way that they respond
to this yesterday before the news came
that the queen had died the white house
was asked about
her ailing the fact that all of her
family members were traveling to her the
fact that it seemed like
uh time was short
the response from karine jean-pierre
i think tells you everything you need to
know about how the left is
how the left stands at this moment in
history
on queen elizabeth she's served for
nearly a third of american history so
how does president biden
view this special relationship between
the u.s and the uk if there were to be a
transition in the british monarchy
so don't wanna you know we feel like
it's inappropriate to talk about uh
hypotheticals here um
we but we what i will say about the
relationship uh with the
with the united kingdom as the president
uh said in celebration of queen's
platinum jubilee which is not too long
ago under and this is quote under her
reign the relationship between the
united kingdom and the united states has
grown stronger and closer than ever the
president as you all know has known the
queen for over three decades he's met
he's met her personally three times once
was in june of 2021
over the years including as i said twice
last year
again
we see
this relationship
is uh stronger grows stronger every um
close stronger and closer
and and again our hearts the presence uh
as he said our thoughts and our hearts
are with the queen her family
and also the people of the united
kingdom
okay perfectly nice thing to say i'm not
criticizing the sentiment at all
i am criticizing the language did you
hear what she said she said and and she
apparently was quoting the president
here
our thoughts and our hearts are with the
queen
that's a strange phrase you don't hear
that for our our thoughts and hearts are
with you
that phrase is a substitute for our
thoughts and prayers are with you but
the white house can't bring itself to
say prayers the left has made a point in
recent years of mocking the phrase
thoughts and prayers and they mock
thoughts and prayers because they
believe that prayers are not efficacious
because they don't believe in god
and and the white house as the
chief representative of the american
left
can't bring itself to to use that phrase
either
i i promise you that was intentional the
omission of the word prayers and maybe
maybe some of them do believe in prayers
but they feel like the base is so
atheistic that they can't use the phrase
or maybe as i suspect
the administration is just not
not particularly christian not
particularly
religious kind of mocks all of those
things
i unfortunately i think it's the latter
really sad because queen elizabeth
in from the earliest days of her reign
was a defender of religion
and public religion private religion too
and private faith and she
viewed herself as serving god and i i
think she did
serve god and she said look people are
in this modern world they're trying to
toss out all the ageless truths and the
ageless ideals namely religion the first
on the list was religion and she said we
really shouldn't do that when we when we
lose that we're really lost
and
when i heard that statement from the
white house it it deepened my sense of
dread that we were going to lose the
queen because i thought man you guys
you guys just don't get it no one seems
to get it or maybe they do get it and
they're
they're happy not that the woman has
passed but that that age has passed and
that sense of tradition and dignity and
and the notion that one serves one's
family and community and country and
ultimately one serves one's god
so many people at funerals think
after they finish thinking about the
person who has died they turn their
thoughts onto themselves and sometimes
people cry at funerals because they're
thinking of their own mortality and it's
a natural reaction i think a lot of
people are thinking that way with the
passing of queen elizabeth we're
thinking about ourselves what does this
mean for the world that we're living in
i had this thought last year i went to
my friend's wedding in france
and took sweet little elisa and
the babies and we made a whole family
trip out of it and we're walking around
paris and sweet little elisa out of
nowhere she's looking at the building
she goes
man
that's obviously elise's voice man meg
why can't we have these beautiful things
how come
how come the french get beautiful things
why don't we get beautiful things
so that's a great question
because there are there are beautiful
buildings in america there's obviously a
lot of beautiful geography but there's
some beautiful art some beautiful
buildings but not a lot they're kind of
few and far between and most of the
buildings that have been built in the
last century have just been these kind
of glass and steel monstrosities or this
brutalist
hideous sort of architecture
you walk around
a city that's from another age
older cities and you think this is so
beautiful
why can't we have that
and that that is the point of the
monarchy that is the point of the royal
family and the last really prominent one
is in the united kingdom is to give the
nation
something to look up to
and it's a service role i mean they you
know these are uh
these are people whose job it is to
serve the country they happen to wear
tiaras but their job is to go out and
open up grocery stores and help
encourage the country
but it's to give them a sense of dignity
not just efficiency not just
you know ticking up the gdp a little
further but a sense of dignity a sense
of tradition a sense of culture a sense
of art
and and the question that we have is why
can't we have that
here
we have a different political tradition
i think i think we could keep cast our
eyes up a little bit but we've we've
really got to dig in deep and not just
cast away all of the past you know
when
when the queen died there were
rainbows that appeared over buckingham
palace and and over windsor castle
when the queen died there was a double
rainbow over buckingham palace and then
when they lowered the flag to half-mast
very briefly a giant rainbow appeared
over windsor castle and it's it's not
lost on me either that the queen died on
mary miss on the feast of the nativity
of mary queen of heaven and earth
i don't think that's just a coincidence
you know i believe in providence i think
that's you know providence is when god
kind of peeks out from behind the
curtain and winks at you
and it is it is a great consolation
because it's a reminder that
no matter
how how useless our good works seem to
be no matter how pointless it seems to
be to live a good life in a culture that
doesn't really seem to reward that all
that much
there is an order to things there is an
overarching providence and we can see it
peak out every now and again and it's
it's a great encouragement
when you want to encourage one and
another you've got to check out pure
talk that way you can talk to each other
right now go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knolls because in a world of takers
puretalk wants to give you something
that's right verizon a t t-mobile
takers
they take too much of your money every
single month for way more data than you
are ever going to need puretalk which is
my cell phone company gives you choices
you only pay for the data that you need
that is how the average family saves
over 75 bucks every single month with
pure talk it's easy to find the right
plan for you and your family unlimited
talk text choose from data plans
from two gigs per month to unlimited
with a mobile hotspot it's whatever you
want all by the way on america's most
reliable 5g network so you're not
sacrificing any coverage whatsoever
here's something else pure talk is going
to give you this month when you switch
to pure talk you pay for one month pure
talk will give you the month number two
for free so do this right now go to
puretalk.com choose your plan then enter
promo code nola's at checkout get your
second month for free that's
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles to
switch to my cell phone company puretalk
speaking of rainbows
great news
out of utah and boise
a utah based bank
has just pulled a sponsorship from an
upcoming boise pride festival
in backlash
to a
drag kids show where children as young
as 11 were set to perform
they say over the years zion's bank has
supported a variety of pride events
because they are an important part of
our support for lgbtq employees and
allies and are representative of our
efforts to foster an inclusive diverse
and equitable workplace and community
this support for all of our employees
and communities remains unchanged but
they said we're not we can't do the kids
stuff okay
we're really open-minded we'll even
support kind of weird sexual parades in
the streets but just leave the kids out
of it please
and the boise pride response was
we can't
we can't
boise says miners have participated in
the boise pride festival both on and off
stage for many years pride and
inclusivity do not begin at age 18. you
know this story was just going around
yesterday i assume it has to date back
to pride month although who knows
actually now not only is pride month in
june
prior there's another version of pride
month in october which is the lgbtq
history month so a full sixth of the
year is now dedicated to uh
eccentric sexual behaviors pretty soon
it's probably gonna be the whole year
regardless of whether this was june or
october the point remains the same
the important takeaway here is
the libs
have to push this on kids
they have to i know a lot of people who
are kind of moderate or in the center
they'll say wow this is just so crazy
the the left the sexual revolutionaries
they can get away with all the pride
stuff they want and put it in public and
probably march the
parade around city hall they can get
some of the biden administration
officials who go to satanic leather or
fetish parties and they could probably
get them to give a keynote speech they
could get away with all of it
if they would just leave the kids out of
it why are these people so stupid why
are they so stubborn that they have to
involve the kids
but they
they have to involve the kids because if
they don't
then they are admitting that the the
events are obscene
right the reason to exclude the kids is
because this is sexually explicit
obscene behavior but if it's sexually
explicit obscene behavior why would we
have it in the public square at all
if this is why they have to trans the
kids too there are people who are in the
middle and centrists who say come on
look if an adult wants to chop his
genitals off that's fine just don't just
don't make the kids do it but they they
have to make the kids do it
because
if they don't have the kids do it then
they are admitting that it doesn't
really make a lot of sense and it's
actually probably disordered and wrong
and you've at least got to wait for if a
kid's going to do something so
destructive as chopping his own genitals
off he should you shouldn't do it when
he's 12. he should at least wait until
he's 18 or 21 or something but but if
it's
very likely disordered and destructive
and all those things
then the adult shouldn't be doing it
either
okay the the what the libs are doing
here is just taking their own premises
to their logical conclusions
men can really be women women can really
be men if a man or woman is sexually
confused they should chop off their
genitals okay if that's the premise
then absolutely you got to take it all
the way and kids should do it too
frankly kids especially should do it
because
once puberty sets in it's going to be a
lot harder to through plastic surgery
make yourself look like the opposite sex
so that's and that's the argument that
the honest libs are making right now
and it makes sense the problem with it
is that the premise is wrong
the problem with it is that the premise
that boys can really be girls that's a
wrong premise the problem with the pride
parade here is that the premise that the
pride parade is wholesome family fun is
just wrong it's not
it's a it's a sexual show
so you might say okay if you don't want
to ban it if you don't if you don't want
to make pass a law against these weird
sex shows fine they should be in the
back dark dingy nightclubs in back dark
dingy alleys of the neighborhoods that
the wholesome people don't go to okay
and there have been shows in those
neighborhoods forever but
there there have been weird things on
the fringes of society since time
immemorial
but you really get into trouble when you
take those things that are on the
fringes of society and put them right
into the center right into the middle of
the town square that's just absurd that
that goes way beyond tolerance that that
that takes tolerance into the realm
truly into the realm of the absurd
so the libs have to double down on all
this stuff and they're doubling down
speaking of our friends in the united
kingdom they're doubling down by turning
a beloved british children's cartoon
gay as well peppa pig i don't i've never
watched peppa pig i guess i could have
started to watch it with my children
soon but i now have no intention of
doing that peppa pig
has gone gay everything else is gay so
peppa pig has gone gay too uh critics
have apparently taken issue with peppa
pig because it glorifies the family and
by the family i mean what is now
called the traditional family i just
call it the family but it's the
traditional family you know mommy and
daddy and the kids and they live
together and they they uh are educated
together and they you know have dinners
together and they function as a family
well some critics have taken issue with
that because on the left they want to
destroy the family because the family is
a great impediment to their cultural and
political revolutions
so in 2019 they started a petition that
demanded that the series creators add a
same-sex couple
not just a same-sex couple by the way
same-sex couple
with
adopted or surrogate children i don't
know how they got children but
with children you know they want to
create this kind of
mimicry this this
this imitation of a family with all the
kind of sexual revolution stuff built in
and so they start this petition it
obviously has nothing to do with the
plot line of the show they just demand
it because it will make them feel better
about their own sort of sexual
ideologies and delusions the petition
has garnered over 23 000 signatures
and now peppa pig has given in
they introduced a
lesbian couple and then the little
the little
baby peppa pig says quote i live with my
mummy and my other mummy so the reaction
from this that you're going to hear from
not just the conservatives but from the
centrist people and the independent
people and the the ones who maybe even
their center left and they say why
deserve why does everything have to be
so political why does everything have to
be so woke
come on why why did
can't you leave the cartoons alone this
is a very common refrain that you hear
from very reasonable people but there's
an answer to it why does everything have
to be woke
because you won't stop it
that's why
because in politics the people who want
something are always going to win
against the people who are indifferent
that's why
because the people
who for whatever ideological or sexual
or repetitive reasons want there to be a
couple of lesbians on this kid's cartoon
they're willing to just go out there and
whine and whine and complain and beg and
shout and boycott and do whatever
and the people who don't want that
very often are not even willing to make
an argument against it
why should there not be a lesbian couple
with kids on the children's cartoon
the answer is because it's disordered
it's very disordered and two ladies
cannot create a child together and so
the only way to do that is by reordering
our adoption system or
creating all sorts of new bioethical
concerns through surrogacy and and in in
vitro fertilization and buying a man's
sperm and renting a woman's womb and all
the rest of it it's all disordered and
it's wrong and it's
morally unacceptable and that's why it
shouldn't be there
very few conservatives are willing to
say that
because they don't want to be called
phobic or bigoted or intolerant or
whatever and so they don't want to say
that all the conservatives are going to
say is come on don't you think
why does it go why has it got to be so
woke it's got to be so woke because you
won't articulate the argument against it
and you won't sign any petitions and you
won't demand it and so the people who
are motivated and who are eager and who
do have a plan and a vision for society
they're the ones who are going to win
and these kind of pathetic platitudes
for neutrality or just come on let's
slow things down or hey let's leave the
kids alone it's not going to go anywhere
the the everything has to be so woke
because the woke people can get away
with it
that's why they can get away with it
because you let them get we got a story
from from social media that's just once
again
the woke people getting away with it
headline here
on
axios
sort of a
center left
outlet
scoop
snaps snapchat snaps political data slip
okay here's how they describe it
a slip up by social media giant snap
allowed leading democratic campaigns and
party committees to unwittingly tap into
a vast repository of republican voter
data to hone their midterm ads
oops
ah darn oh i just those darn slip-ups
those darn slip-ups they're so
frustrating because they're always made
so unwittingly aren't they and it's just
such a weird
unwitting coincidence that the slip-ups
always benefit the democrats
and they never benefit the republicans
oops oopsie daisy
yeah the fbi got the fisa warrant wrong
and they actually didn't yeah they
didn't have any reason to spy on the
trump campaign that was a big mistake
our bad
yeah our bad we totally won't do this
again whoopsie daisy
oops hillary clinton had a private email
server where she had classified
information and at the same time she was
raising a ton of money from foreign
governments for her own personal charity
charity quote unquote to pay her own
bills oops
oopsie daisy no big deal
whoops what a slip up we won't let that
happen again
[Music]
oh by the way oops former president
trump took some documents from the white
house as lots of presidents have done
yeah we're going to kick in his door
we're not letting that slip up go
through uh-uh
no siree
uh we caught that mistake we just don't
catch it when social media companies
give democrats a major advantage in the
in the elections
oopsie
i think those slip-ups are going to keep
happening they're going to keep
unwittingly happening unless we stop
them
unless
we
on the happy occasions that we can get
any political power and it's always
going to be an uphill battle because
let's say the republicans retake the
house maybe there's a shot we retake the
senate
we're still not going to have the
bureaucracy we're not going to have the
presidency we sort of have the supreme
court but it's
marginal we don't have the media we
don't have big tech we don't have the
universities we don't we don't have
really any of the other power centers
but
okay we can get a little bit of the
government
we have to wield that power we have to
wield the force of big government you
know this will make certain american
conservatives feel uneasy but we have to
wield the force of big government
against our political adversaries in a
just way in a moral way in an
appropriate way but we have to do it
because these slip-ups are not just
these slip-ups are not
appropriate these slip-ups are not moral
you can't have a good system with these
slip-ups the slip-ups aren't slip-ups
okay they're just democrats taking
advantage because they know they can get
away with it
speaking of slip ups
you might recall
what was this a week or two ago
there was a trade show trade conference
for podcasting called podcast movement
that held its convention
and since the daily wire is the sixth
largest publishing network in the world
and since ben shapiro in particular is
always in one of the very tippy top
ranked podcasts but all of our shows
consistently chart very very high up on
uh in podcasting
among all shows not just among political
shows or conservative shows because of
that
the daily wire had a booth there and ben
showed up and took some pictures with
some fans who were at the podcast
movement and then he walked out that was
it and podcast movement issued this long
uh condemnation of ben and daley wire
and said it's unacceptable and you know
people felt unsafe and you know it was
really
really bizarre kind of behavior
and really wrong
well i've got some good news on that
front
a
podcast movement then posted
they said we're listening to the podcast
movement community
we're putting in place policies to guide
our social media with inclusivity and
diversity and respect it's a journey
right that was that was part of their
condemnation of ben but then they just
just yesterday tweeted out quote as we
stated we're continuing to evaluate our
policies guiding social media and events
with inclusivity diversity and respect
for all we have to start by sincerely
apologizing to mr shapiro for our
reaction when he visited a booth we sold
to his company that wasn't right
and uh
that's all true
that's good and i i also know that the
president of podcast movement did call
jeremy and made very very clear that
the behavior podcast movement was
unacceptable and he you know he took it
like a man
the president of podcast movement and he
called and he did the right thing and he
apologized and he said what they did was
just was just totally wrong and and so
my reaction here i know that some people
would like to you know
double down and keep keep hitting
podcast movement but i think we live in
an age that is so graceless and where no
one ever
gets to
hear a sincere apology or no one usually
accepts a sincere apology so i think
it's good i'm glad podcast movement
apologized
we accept the apology
good that's good they did the right
thing
i appreciate that they did the right
thing
so people very rarely do the right thing
anymore they just double down when
they're when they're so obviously wrong
and so uh that's good i appreciate that
i think it's very big of podcast
movement to do that and i'm i'm pleased
to see it not just for us but but for
what it means for conservatives in the
podcasting space
and uh
and in the culture and in the public
square so good good stuff
appreciate that
good job podcast movement
speaking of uh double standards
this is a really crazy story
a
a democrat
public official has just been arrested
on suspicion of murdering a reporter
and you probably haven't heard anything
about this story
there was a story you saw the headlines
the other day in in maybe some
conservative outlets that a reporter
from nevada who some said had been
doing a report on that that shooting in
las vegas but i'm not sure that that was
necessarily the key the reporter just
generally had been investigating crime
and corruption
this guy ended up murdered
and and now the chief suspect is this
clark county democrat official
whose dna was found at the scene
the guy is the clark county public
administrator robert tellies
he was just booked
uh
i mentioned the story because
we talked about the double standards
yesterday on racism
you know the the libs when they when
they use this phrase racism
it doesn't mean anything they are
whatever racism could possibly mean
they're much more guilty of it than the
republicans and the republicans sort of
effectlessly say no no you're the real
racist and it doesn't matter you're the
hypocrites yeah okay they know that they
don't care okay they they're going to do
it anyway because they can get an
advantage over you same thing with
political violence the libs decry
political violence they commit much much
more political violence than the
conservatives have even just in the last
few years again we point out the double
standard nobody really cares well i i
would like to point it out just again
only for the conservatives to realize
this it's true on journalism too the
libs attack journalists much more than
the conservatives do the obama
administration was very very tough on
journalists uh we remember really
bizarre political pressure on reporters
like james rosen or sheryl atkinson
but now we're seeing this a democrat
official murdering a
uh
an investigative reporter for for
looking into corruption
i mention it not because i think that
pointing out the double standard is
finally going to shift there if no i
don't think it will i mention it just as
a little encouragement to conservatives
when and and to people in the center
when the libs start getting on their
soapbox about how the republicans are
threatening a free press just remember
it's completely bogus it's a pointless
argument it's not true anything that
they are saying about the republicans
they are projecting they are confessing
what they themselves are doing so just
ignore it
i'm not encouraging people to just you
know go out and point out the hypocrisy
and and that's how we're going to win
the argument no that's not going to
happen they don't care they know about
the hypocrisy they just want to get one
over on us but i'm saying this is a word
of encouragement to the republicans just
ignore it it means nothing it's just a
cheap political lie move on okay these
these guys are just trying to take
advantage of you i'm very very excited
that we will get to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
all of you in the mail bag our mail bag
is sponsored by pure talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code knowlescanwles to get your second
month for free let's take it away with
the voicemail back
hello michael
i'll save you the backstory but my wife
and i were recently discussing what we
would like to happen with our bodies
after we die
be it burial cremation or something else
i'm curious about what what option you
think is best
i'd assume you're a proponent of
traditional burials
maybe there's a
catholic teaching behind that i'm
unaware of
anyway if my assumption is correct i'd
like to know why you think that way
and what reasons there are behind
being against cremation for example
and if i'm wrong
i'd be surprised but if you do think
differently then please elaborate
thanks michael
yes i'm very much against cremation i am
for
burial or a mausoleum if you want to get
fancy but i'm very much against
cremation
the the church traditionally
opposed cremation and forbade it uh in
recent years they've gone softer on
cremation but i still oppose it and the
reason i oppose it
is because it makes a mockery of the
resurrection of the body if you are a
christian
you believe in the resurrection of the
body not just that we're going to go to
heaven not just that our souls will be
at peace and that we will behold the
face of our creator in the baitific
vision
you you believe in the actual
resurrection of the body and this is
very important to the way that we well
the way that we view our bodies and our
own behaviors and the way that we view
creation in the world that we're not
just disembodied spirits but the body
really matters too and the body and soul
and spirit are united inextricably
during our lives they are separated at
the moment of our death but that our
bodies will be resurrected and so
i'm not making any eschatological claims
about what it means
if one is cremated in the resurrection
of the body i am just pointing out as a
matter of symbolism and the
ritual and
um
the way that we treat our bodies in the
creative world the way that we interact
with the physical things of this world
to to
cremate oneself is to mock the
resurrection of the body and so i would
strongly advise against it next question
mr nostradamus this is smiling sam alvi
i was listening to your show while
driving my kids to their private school
because we are done with the public
school system my little girl nine years
old she was listening to you as we do
most mornings and you started talking
about eating bugs and how you know
delicious they're supposed to be and
stuff like that that got her interested
that piqued her interest and so she
asked daddy
they want us to eat bugs and i said oh
yes they do and then turned into a whole
conversation about how cows fart and
causes global warming and how everything
they do is just to try and find a way to
control us similar to the masks
they know they don't taste good but
they're gonna force us to eat it just so
they can say that they forced us to do
it and she looked up and said well daddy
joe biden's not gonna eat bugs is he and
i could not have been more proud it was
a moment of oh she connected the dots
she knows that those in charge aren't
gonna eat bugs they're just gonna make
us eat bugs or try to anyways i guess i
always knew i was gonna have that time
where i had to talk about the virgin
beast my daughter but i guess it was
today but not the birds and the bees it
was the bugs in the beach
thank you for your work and uh we'll
keep listening smiling sam alvey all
right uh your daughter is very
insightful obviously
yes the
elites who want to get us all to eat
bugs they will be eating filet mignon
that is true
as a general rule that is true
and
there's a caveat to this
i don't think that the elites regularly
will eat bugs but i do think that they
will
temporarily or
infrequently or even as a matter of
initiation eat the bugs i think they
will do it you think of
that actress uh what is her name the one
who was married to tom cruise
i forget she just did a whole video
where she came out and ate a bunch of
bugs and it was disgusting you sometimes
see
bill gates uh came out and i think it
was he drank a glass of water that came
out of
fecal matter or some one of the just
some of all of these gross things eating
the bugs living in excrement all of this
gross stuff sometimes the elites
themselves do it
and they do it in order to shatter a
taboo they do it for the same reason
that fraternities haze their pledges
okay they do it because
it it is a way to express and actually
reinforce one's commitment to a group
or to a secret society or to a cult
which is probably more like it
so that is the reason why are they why
are they forcing us to eat the bugs it's
it's not that they're thinking look we
need new sources of protein and yes the
bugs are gross but that's what we have
to do in order to get the protein it's
it's actually the other way around
they're saying man we have a taboo in
our culture against eating bugs so if we
want to upend the culture we have to eat
the bugs
we actually we have to do it because it
is so gross
that will
break the taboos because taboos and
standards to find cultures and so when
you when you shatter them and you
reorder them you are reordering the
culture in a very very profound way
that's a lot of what's going on with the
bug eating and the protein and the
efficiency and getting all the poor
masses to eat cheaper sources of protein
and uh and creating uh
even greater inequality between the poor
and the elites that that goes along with
it but i think the taboos are really
central to it okay next question
hey knowles pete calling from uh
nova scotia canada
i work outdoors at night in utter
darkness at a golf course
watering mostly not that you ask but
i do have a request hey
let's cool it on the demons are
everywhere all the time and out to get
you rhetoric
oh okay i'm getting a little freaked out
out here i'm pretty sure i just saw uh
belfagore and three lesser demons teeing
off on four here okay let's cool it down
a shade thanks a lot my friend you're
doing a great job always enjoy listening
to you bye-bye now
an understandable objection but i
actually have a different take on it
when i was a
teenager and my atheist
debauched degenerate years
i was much more superstitious than i am
now
i was much more spooked by the demons
that i didn't think existed than i am
now when i am convinced that demons
really do exist and are surrounding us
all the time because we're we are
surrounded by uh
a battlefield we are we are actually in
a battlefield of spiritual combat
the reason is
because i believe that uh christ
conquers death and sin on the cross and
you know saint michael just
stabs that dragon with the sword and our
lady crushes the serpent underneath her
heel and uh i think the game is won you
know and christ harrows hell and so
we're going to win i'm on i'm on the
winning team so i don't worry about
those stupid little demons i think of
saint john vianney who was tormented by
the devil and he used to make fun of the
devil
he was a he's the patron of parish
priests and he was in this little town
ours in france and he was tormented by
the devil and he would just make fun of
him he'd call him was you know his
little stupid guy his lagrepan you know
there he is again here we go you know
ignore him no big deal he set my dead on
fire okay no big deal and i i think
that's the right attitude
i think uh
when people want to deny
dangers and realities they actually
whether they're physical or whether
they're metaphysical
they they tend to get much more freaked
out by it you know it's it's kind of
gets back to that old saying
if you believe in nothing you'll fall
for anything
but if you believe in something
especially if you believe in something
true
then you'll be much more grounded i i
just find that the atheists tend to be
the most superstitious people on earth
and they'll fall for any kind of weird
new age manifesting sending vibes
playing with my crystals man kind of
stuff and it's the christians especially
the christians who take the religion
seriously who are much more grounded and
you might expect it to be the opposite
you might expect christians who believe
in you know god and incarnation and
choirs of angels and demons trying to
attack us and take our soul you might
expect them to be really really out
there but they're not i mean if you've
just ever spoken to
a a serious christian who takes the
religion seriously they're the least
superstitious people on earth okay
next question
hi michael thank you so much for your
advice on
volunteering for a political campaign my
uncle is in the gun business and has
connections with andrew clyde who is
campaigning for my district so i'm going
to volunteer with his campaign
um i have kind of a weird
question today that involves singing in
mass so i'm catholic i go to mass every
sunday with my family and
i sing at every mass along with my mom
my grandmother and my sister
because we believe it is
another almost higher form of prayer
however most of the people who attend
mass do not sing including my brothers
i've been trying to encourage my
one brother to sing for a while now but
i think he's just too embarrassed since
so many people
in the church don't sing
i was wondering what's your opinion on
singing in mass and
do you have any advice on how i can
convince him to sing thanks love the
show
thank you so much great question great
to hear that you're on that campaign and
i have many thoughts on this question
that you've just raised i think it was
saint augustine who says that to sing
well is to pray twice so it's good to
sing it's good to sing in praise but
you're right people in
the what's called the new mass or the
mass of pope paul vi that's the mass
that started in 1970 and has got
replaced in most places the traditional
latin mass that had endured for almost
two millennia
that mass at that mass people don't
really sing that much which is ironic
because the point of that new mass
was to increase participation and yet
participation in many ways decreased i
think the reason for that it's not just
the your brother's fault and it's not
just the the fault of the people in the
congregation
it's because the mass
is is really
the new form of that liturgy is much
more shallow and much more effeminate
and the hymns that replaced the
traditional chanting and the traditional
hymns in the mass are really sappy
effeminate 1970s pop songs
that make some references to god and are
often heretical and so
it's it to me it's perfectly
understandable that a young man would
not want to sing
some
shallow you know song about i will raise
you up on
swings and first of all that's i won't
raise anybody up on eagle's wings
because i'm not god so it's the songs
have theological problems and they're
just so lame and sappy they weren't even
cool in the 70s and so i'm not surprised
at all
i'm not surprised that people don't want
to participate in that that really
shallow kind of liturgy and so what i
would recommend well i frequently
recommend that people if if you are
catholic i would recommend you attend
the traditional latin mass if you can
find one
but but if you can't let's say you want
to just keep going to your church and
you know go to the
mass of paul vi okay fine
you might want to encourage the musical
director there to bring back some
sturdier
more masculine more serious uh hymns
than the kind of
silly stuff that came out of the 70s
because that
it's i i get it i get it if i went to
those masses i wouldn't want to sing it
either
i wanna i wanna i i don't wanna offend
our lord
but with uh with bad music okay i don't
insipid twaddle as a priest friend of
mine describes a lot of those songs all
right when saint augustine says to sing
well is to pray twice
but to sing poorly i don't know i don't
know what that comes down to okay one
one written question before we get into
the member block michael i only just
started watching your show in the past
few weeks you've quickly become my
favorite host by far though thank you
very much that's very kind uh here's a
question should i engage in any sexual
acts with my girlfriend before marriage
all right we're really jumping right to
it uh we've been dating for a little
over five months i love her she's never
asked for anything and i don't plan on
doing anything until we get married if
that happens frankly i feel that
anything more than making out is too
much for dating
and would make the relationship more
complicated is there anything wrong with
that thank you mr knowles and have a
nice day so you're asking me how far
around the bases you're allowed to run
yeah you're right you're right you
should you should not you should refrain
from sexual activity until you're
married most people do not do that
especially people who were you know kind
of atheists for a lot of their youth
but i i will say
some of those people i think regret
their behaviors when they go too fast
too far with the number of women and i
think it's a very special wonderful
thing if you can refrain from that kind
of behavior until you get married and
the bonus of that is it will encourage
you to get married sooner which uh
usually
almost all the time will be to your
benefit and it will at least
force you to think about whether or not
you want to get married to this person
and if not you can move on that that's
really that clarity will certainly be to
your benefit the rest of the show is
continuing now
you do not want to miss it if you are
not a member click on the link in the
description and join us we've got
five stories from the week four real
headlines one fake headline the
producers have compiled them i have to
guess which is the fake headline you
have to guess which is the fake headline
the way the news cycle goes it becomes
very very difficult plus we got more
mailbag and i will hear from you live
okay we'll see you at the member blog
[Music]
[Music]
you